through a combination of intelligence
talent and sheer will Melody Hobson has
worked her way up through the top ranks
of American Business she's the president
and co-ceo of aerial Investments the
nation's oldest black owned investment
fund she also serves on a number of
corporate boards including Starbucks
where she's chair and JP Morgan Chase
now Hobson spearheading a new private
Equity Fund alongside industry veteran
Leslie brune called project black its
mission to get more black Executives
into the upper tiers of the business
World by connecting them with both
customers and capital
so project black was an idea that was
born really during all of The Strife
that occurred after the horrific murder
of George Floyd I had this idea what if
we could scale large minority businesses
because the data is actually stunning 95
of black and brown businesses in this
country have less than five million
dollars in Revenue at the time of all
the civil unrest with George Floyd's
murder many corporations were pledging
to do more business with black and brown
companies and one of the things they
said was at that point they were doing
about two percent of their spend 125
billion dollars with minority businesses
but a goal of 10 to 15 percent which
means there's a trillion dollar
opportunity but we have the scale
challenge because our businesses are so
small so I said what if we could
actually buy Middle Market businesses by
virtue of our ownership my word
minoritize those businesses bring in
black and brown Executives change the
nature of those businesses with their
boards with their leaders ultimately
create businesses that are the preferred
vendors tier one suppliers
on February 1st aerial Alternatives
closed its first project black fund with
1.45 billion in commitments from
investors such as former Microsoft CEO
Steve Ballmer Walmart Salesforce and the
Qatar investment Authority that's on top
of an up to 200 million dollar
co-investment commitment JP Morgan made
when the fund was announced
Hobson's determination to see project
black deliver largely reflects on her
character and professional reputation
she grew up the youngest of six to a
single mother experiencing financial
hardship in her early years but even
with the odds of success stacked against
her Hobson was accepted to both Harvard
and Princeton ultimately choosing the
latter
this is how she came to meet John Rogers
the founder of aerial Investments thank
you
I was volunteering for the Princeton
schools committee which is the committee
that in local communities where you're
trying to make sure the local alumni are
interviewing prospective students and I
was ultimately Vice chairman and then
chairman of the schools committee really
committed to recruiting diverse students
to Princeton and I met Melody as a
prospective student
he came to all the Adventure Reigns for
all students and for minority students
you can see right then she was just
really special she had so much Charisma
so much energy she was so thoughtful and
smart you know she just shine in this
industry you're going to have some
really big ups and some really big downs
and you need a business partner who's
going to stick with you through those
tough times and be able to not get
frightened by the short-term pain make
the tough decisions and use her judgment
in the right way and so I always say
there's no one you'd want more to be in
a foxhole with than Melody Hobson
in its 40 years Ariel has certainly gone
through tough times the 1987 crash
the.com era and the most harrowing of
all the 2008 Global financial crisis to
give you an idea the fund went from 21
billion dollars in assets under
management in 2004 to just 3.3 billion
in March 2009 but the fund ultimately
rebounded and has managed to continue
successfully thanks to its principles
these include its contrarian Buy and
Hold approach and reputation for active
patients with project black there's a
particular strategy Hobson is betting on
as its keys to success
[Music]
when I was growing up through Ariel John
Rogers always used to say to me the
founder of Ariel when people talk about
black businesses they talk about access
to Capital Access to Capital Access to
Capital and John said to me access to
customers may be more important then I
went on the board of JP Morgan and I was
sitting in that boardroom and I realized
very quickly being on the board of the
eighth largest bank in the world the
largest bank in America if you have a
fistful of receivables they will lend
you money so I said the customer is
actually more important the customer
becomes the conduit to the Capitol and
so we stepped back and said to ourselves
we need to create a situation where the
customer becomes the way to drive the
change
the total committed to project black is
five times the size of the average first
time private Equity Fund and brings
assets under management and aerial to
just above 16 billion project Black's
first investment was made last year when
it acquired just over 52 percent of
utah-based Sorensen Communications at an
Enterprise value of 1.3 billion and
already big changes have been made the
company went from having one person of
color in the c-suite and boardroom to 13
and the new CEO is Jorge Rodriguez a
veteran Telecom exec who worked with
Mexican billionaire Carlos Slim
over the next three to five years
project black plans to buy and expand
Platforms in six to ten other supplier
segments such as Financial and
Professional Services Healthcare
technology manufacturing and Logistics I
think it's a very simple call to action
is you put your money where your mouth
is so many people say and stayed in
intention but coming through is actually
financially doing something about it so
in Corporate America there's been so
much talk about equality and diversity
and Equity show me the map show me the
commitment of the dollars show me the
diversity of the c-suite show me the
diversity of the board and I can tell
you who's really serious